imagine you're driving through the hot
Moroccan desert your car breaks down and
the nearest village is 20 miles away
would you panic would you give up would
you convert your car into a motorbike in
a lengthy process that might get you
killed eats a meal the Ray the
mechanical magician who did just that
close to a small town in France there is
a man that loves cars
who specifically the French Citroen 2cv
like those
[Music]
and he's got this funny-looking
motorbike with an extraordinary story
behind it Oh meaning of socket holdup -
just use a glioma or something to
continuously do new voice for nipple MC
so [ __ ] when you would on TV - 17m zoom
in a minute my IT community Imam Mahdi
the yoga session are at the auto
attendant
excuse me preferred on KGC Muni how it
works oftentimes if a document known as
European actually did we had a dementia
see obviously like any stranded desert
traveler amel decided to turn the still
working parts of that car into this
motorbike first he removed the cars
frame said yes Mousavi nippon-ichi can
Masami that when sitting mamizou judo
meter then we come on epoch then he
shortened it to make a better chassis
fix the axles and put the wheels on the
bike simple right no oh yeah he also
added suspension and well an engine and
ignition and a comfortable seat after 12
days and 11 nights in the desert he was
ready to go back to civilization jeffina
Puente sighs really didn't he do 50
into that machine GT to move out more as
a superhit on this day on the island
attempted finally to his delight he came
upon the police who greeted him with
hefty fine
caffeine sanctions I can't to DRS key
figures are second to all the season
consider like motion unit to be fulfill
my captive in a dish for back in France
the motorcycle ended up alongside
Emile's other Citroen creations like
this boat this rugby ball a table saw
and even glasses made out of rubber from
the seat the sky really lost Citron's
who makes you wonder what's next
[Music]